So, let's discuss, can compilers help improve IPC? Which
is the number of instructions per cycle, that the processor
achieves. There are really two things that the compiler can
help with. One, is the ILP of the program itself
may be limited. For example, due to dependence chains,
which is when we have instructions that depend on each
other, so really if we have a long chain like
this then there will be very limited ILP in this
program because we can really execute only one instruction
at a time. So, the compiler, as we will
see, might help us actually avoid these kinds of
dependence chains. And also, the hardware has a limited
window into the program. For example, there might be
independent instructions, so an ideal processor might be able
to achieve good ILP on that program. But because
these independent instructions are far apart, a real processor
simply can not see those instructions. Because, for example, it
runs out of ROB space before it reaches those instructions if
they're independent. So, in the same example, if we have
a long chain like this followed by, this instruction doesn't depend
on any of those in the chain, but if the
chain is too long, we run out of ROB space before
we reach this instruction. So, as far as this processor
is concerned, this instruction cannot execute in parallel with those just
because we never see it. As we will see,
the compiler can help us put these independent instructions
closer to each other, so that the IPC achieved
by the processor is closer to the available ILP.